[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's good and welcome everybody to the
idea xbox showcase i'm andrea renee from
what's good games joined by okadran
what's good man
you know there's no better place to be
than right here with you talking about
video games specifically indie games
this is exactly what's good
i'm so excited to be back hosting for
this showcase specifically i had such a
fun time back at the winter gathering
looking at a bunch of indie games back
then and now we have even more exclusive
trailers dev interviews all kinds of
stuff on today's show we're going to be
celebrating as adrian said in the xbox
games and it's just going to be i think
a really fun jam-packed um couple of
hours
yeah people are already in a good mood
you see down there people in the chat
are saying hello they're saying woo
they're excited to be here they want to
see games and honestly that that just
puts you in the mood to talk about games
the entire time to have an audience that
wants to see it too
absolutely
look at that woo indie game hype the
entire time that's exactly what i want
to see right there and twitch chat just
reminder we can see everything you're
typing so if you wouldn't type it to
someone that you care about don't type
it here but it's about indie games so
it's nothing but love the entire time
and hey throughout the day we'll be
dropping exclusive new game trailers and
let you know what games are coming to
game pass
when
will we tell you about a game dropping
on game pass it's a very good question
right so we'll put a timer timer about
let's say
in eight minutes or so and then when we
do that we'll be revealing a surprise
announcement okay wow it's already seven
minutes and 49 seconds that's how
quickly it happens okay so specific
well you know people make sure that
means
stay on task we don't want to be late
for the timer um but chat as adrian
mentioned we love that you guys are
involved here on twitch gaming you guys
hear us say it all the time that you
guys are a big part of the show so keep
the comments and the emotes coming we
love to see them and uh we apparently
are on a countdown
yeah we're going to count down the
entire time and want to make sure that
everyone knows we see the countdown and
just means good games are coming your
way and you want to make sure everybody
knows this is a co-streamable event if
you don't know what that means it means
doesn't matter if your partner affiliate
whatever you want to be it means you can
take the url above that's the twitch
gaming url you can go in obs obs you can
go to xsplit open up a browser source
paste it there and then add the code
streaming tag to your stream and you can
sit back and watch with your own channel
and do everything we're doing right now
with your own peeps
heck yes and i know that the folks over
at g4 tv mentioned that they are
co-streaming so shout out to you guys
what's good
but let's go ahead i was hoping they
would answer shall we
[Laughter]
so throughout today's show the idiot
xbox twitch gaming indie game showcase
as we mentioned we will be airing new
game trailers for the very first time so
no so new in fact that even we haven't
seen the trailers yet so normally during
rehearsal they show us the trailers not
this time it's gonna be all surprises
for everybody so share your reactions in
the chat with us because we're excited
to hear what you guys have to say and we
hope that you are ready because let's go
ahead and start off with some new
trailers
[Music]
[Music]
i never meant for any of this to happen
all this
bloodshed
all this
chaos
brother against brother
i feel like
trapped on a path they can't change
we used to be mercenaries
then they called us criminals
so we became rebels
and now
a revolution
we didn't start this war
but one way or another
we're gonna end it
[Music]
i'll do whatever it takes
to bring my people home
and no king
no friend
nothing
will stop me
[Music]
[Music]
i'm emperor t-pain
i'm going to teach you how to rule in
crusader kings 3. this is a game of
choices and building strong healthy
relationships i'm going to rewrite
history just by being fair and just
making peace with my neighbors no matter
their religion or culture letting my
kids marry for love
educating the masses and lowering taxes
it's gonna be a utopia so first let me
see i'll just uh
oh
okay
well um
well that's new okay minor inconvenience
we're gonna keep moving forward and
continue my dynasty's mission on
peaceful
[ __ ]
uh
i'm gonna have to reevaluate this whole
thing
we'll be back um you know what second
step just marry off all your kids don't
even matter if he's a troll just aim for
very powerful and wealthy alliances
nothing else matters third find the
shadiest slim in the land and have them
start murdering all your neighbors
that's going to trigger a secession
crisis when all of them die imprison all
the rebel families holding hostages if
you had to we're going to take care of
this one rebellion real quick and then
right back to peace promise fourth we're
going to need mercenaries to replenish
our army
that just means raising taxes
temporarily we need to protect our
borders
those neighbors are looking pretty sus
we can build that university after we
take this one neighbor and then and then
we're good
oh
[ __ ]
take control of history on march 29th
with xbox game pass
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you just
stunned at how adorably cute tunic is or
are you still chuckling that t-pain
raised or raised taxes after he said he
was gonna keep taxes low in his utopia
uh see all the above
my homies said raise taxes temporarily
for the holy booty empire and every
politician says the same thing
which means he's playing the game the
right way i'm sure his empire is going
to do quite well tunic looked
outstanding it's been looking
outstanding for years now and the fact
that it's just like so close it's no
more just watching trailers and we're
going to play it that's
beyond great
yeah it's awesome that it's finally out
it's out today and it's coming to xbox
game pass today as well which is an
incredible value as we mentioned the top
of the show we're going to be talking
about games pass a lot and i saw a bunch
of people in chat talking about how they
love that game pass introduces them to
games they might not have otherwise got
to play or maybe even heard about and
there's a bunch of those in the showcase
today so keep your eyes peeled but i do
want to give tpain a shout out for that
gold controller i'm like where can i get
one of those
he had the four royal kit right there
and like you said about tunic game
coming to game pass true and we're going
to let you know actually when it's live
for you to play which is why you want to
stay tuned and later good news because
we're all about streamers here on twitch
we're going to check in with the
streamer ash said hi who will be playing
tunic live on her channel so if you
couldn't get enough you want a quick
preview someone else playing it someone
who loves retro style games and it's
retro aesthetic perfect person to have
compliment that game
absolutely uh what did you think about
the first trailer that we saw last idol
ons
i thought it looked really good and one
of the things that i loved about it is
that during one of the skirmishes i saw
the protagonist one shot someone like i
was looking at the health bar and i was
waiting to see it kind of chop down one
by one he swung once health evaporated
anytime i can do that i feel like a
gamer god and the opening cinematic
style and the fighting reminded me of a
game called lost odyssey on the 360. uh
kyme was his name and the opening battle
was the same way when you attack one
enemy and there's a big giant army
behind them when they fight it looked
outstanding
that is a deep cuffs reference i'm here
for it i love it
yeah all right well listen we gotta keep
this show moving we've got a jam-packed
show today and so we're gonna go ahead
and get our first guest on you may know
him as the director and writer of games
that push the boundaries of interactive
narratives with silent hill shattered
memories he created a classic game that
psychologically profiled its players and
in her story he reinvented the detective
genre for the youtube generation his new
project immortality is his most
ambitious yet but before we say hi to
sam barlow let's take a look at the
trailer for immortality
[Music]
all right well we've gotta take a short
break here do you mind reading this out
for us
now marvelous magic will turn the next
60 seconds into a commercial
marissa
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
did we get it right
[Music]
give us a turn
it's not who you think
[Music]
is she okay
[Music]
now you can proposition me
sam welcome to the show thanks so much
for showing us your new trailer for
immortality how are you doing today
i'm good i'm glad we just saw the
trailer because i was totally thinking
all about tunic
that's exciting
i know right
the little fox is going to be on
everybody's mind i love that already in
the chat root boy root says these
graphics are so realistic maybe not
realizing the use of fmv do you find
that maybe some of the newer generations
of gamers don't really understand what
fmv is because not a lot of games use it
these days
yeah i mean i think there's definitely
a novelty value there like when i first
saw her story was the kind of game where
i i got into this thing and
that game came out of
just being aware of how prevalent video
was right like when i grew up if you
want to watch a video you had to go get
a video cassette and stick it in some
big heavy machine and play around with
it
now you're just watching video on your
phone sharing videos like it's it's
you know as accessible as text or
anything else would be
so that kind of was the spark for me was
was thinking like what do you do with
people's familiarity with video how do
you make that into something that's
interactive and interesting so it's kind
of coming in it from a very different
perspective
i love how you mentioned that video so
ubiquitous i think it's something a lot
of us take for granted just how much
it's a part of our daily lives and i
think that's what's so fascinating about
what you do as a storyteller and the way
that you craft your games and continue
to push the envelope with the way that
you use video what can fans of yours and
newcomers alike expect to find in the
storytelling of immortality
so the idea here is to uh take
some of the stuff i've done before so
i've
kind of been digging into this idea of
almost a metroidvania video right it's
like how do you tell an interactive
story
uh which is as open as an open world
game which has as much kind of
expressivity as those kind of games but
but in a very different way so in my
games you'll be
utterly free to explore the story kind
of in any direction and sort of follow
your own curiosity and the way it works
here is
if you can imagine uh there's the scene
in a horror movie or a thriller where
someone goes into the library and
they're going through like the old
microfiche cats you know
going through the kind of archives and
digging up
old stories and bits and pieces or
watching you know old cursed videotapes
uh that's kind of the vibe here so we
have marissa marcel who is an actress
who in the late 60s uh kind of starred
in her first movie and somehow
she only ever films three movies and
none of those movies has ever made it
out so these are kind of these rare lost
movies that no one has ever seen or
heard of since and no one knows what
happened to marissa marcel and so the
player is going to go into the game and
be digging through hours and hours of
this archive of pieces of film and
footage from these lost movies that
we've discovered and put together and so
you're kind of investigating watching
these movies putting together the
stories of the movies themselves but
also kind of digging into the behind the
scenes and kind of figuring out what in
fact happened to marissa marcel um so
you know you have this really
self-driven kind of expressive way of
interacting with a story uh you know if
you have
something that you've noticed or you're
particularly interested in you can kind
of dig into that area so you know these
games tend to be very fun to play on a
couch with your partner
where you know you're both having ideas
and theories about what's going on and
you can discuss them as and when you're
playing so with this one it was really
important to us to from the start think
about the living room experience have
this on xbox have this be something that
you can sit back and play together and
really dig into as well this cinematic
texture so you know
my love of movies and the kind of 20th
century classic filmmaking this is also
a very deep dive into how movies are
made who makes them
you know how do movies work we really
want players to
you know
think about how movies work think about
what it is to watch a movie and kind of
give them the tools to do that
i mean you pretty much summed up
i think people's excitement about this
game in a nutshell it looks awesome so i
see that there's like three individual
components are players able to kind of
jump around or is it more of a crafted
experience where you go at them one at a
time
so actually it's very free i think with
my last game i was referencing a lot of
open world games um it was kind of how i
saw it you know when you start up an
open world game
you can go in any direction north south
east west and you might see a little
something i'm going to see a you know a
small building on a hill and want to go
there and here it's the story content
itself so from the start
um you start with a very limited amount
of footage that's available to you and
the the beautiful mechanic that we have
this time is
as you're watching a piece of footage
and and everything you're watching
is done through this interface which
recalls like a classic moviola machine
right when movies were made on film when
you're editing them you have these big
loud heavy machines and you're rewinding
moving through the footage splicing it
together and we've tried to kind of
recreate that using modern technology
and
when you're watching a scene if you see
something that interests you and this is
kind of magical and i love it
you just pause the footage and
click on that thing so if you see a
character and you see the face of a
character you've not seen before or a
prop so someone takes out a gun or a
dagger and you're like well that's going
places uh or maybe you're digging into
the imagery in the movie you're like
well hey i keep seeing pieces of fruit
or a particular animal that clearly
means something in this movie you'll
click on that and then the code will in
real time generate a match cut and cut
to another piece of footage in which
that item appears so you're essentially
assembling your own
super cut of this movie um and using
those visual elements using characters
stories plots pieces you know props
as this way of exploring as the kind of
breadcrumb trail so very quickly
your individual curiosity and what
you're responding to is what kind of
drives you through this and it becomes a
very visual experience
that is
sounds so awesome like i love a good
mystery and it seems like it's going to
be super interactive and i know people
are pumped to play and i wish i could
keep chatting with you about it but we
do have to unfortunately say goodbye but
i want you to tell people where can they
learn more about immortality and when
can they play
uh they'll be able to play uh we're
saying currently summer of this year so
very soon uh we're in the final stages
um if they want to hear more they can go
to halfmermaid.com
check us out on twitter at half mermaid
um and we'll you know as we get closer
start to peel back some of the layers i
think we've told people before that this
is an investigative horror game um and
uh you know the first people the first
question people ask me is like in what
way is this a horror like what's the
horror element where is the darkness
and maybe we'll start to peel back some
of that as as people kind of uh get
closer to launch
well we gotta leave something for player
discovery though right
that's the key it was so hard
i just want you to show up good yeah
mom's the word everybody well sam thank
you so much for your time today and
enjoy the rest of your day and everyone
you can um look forward to immortality
hopefully later this summer
thank you
all right everybody we're going to take
a quick break but don't go anywhere
because we've got more trailers more
gameplay more idea and xbox showcase
coming up next
you're the unique among the uncommon
you've fought for our freedoms your
bravery and leadership is celebrated by
all americans at grand canyon university
we recognize your commitment to
excellence our commitment is to deliver
modern online degree programs that can
help you or your spouse pursue the next
step in your journey we salute you god
bless america find your purpose at gcu
private christian affordable visit
gcu.edu
military
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to idea xbox
happy to have you here to boy occasion
joined by andrea bernay we're hanging
out and we will make sure that you all
participate in chat to talk with us and
speak with us about all the good things
happening loving the comments so far
someone said i hope for some crusader
kings 3 news guess what we had some
footage earlier so if you want to you
can watch the vod and check that out
we have some stuff coming up later on we
got it check box and i do want to call
out one comment that i saw from darth
moca that says this has got to be
pre-recorded and it's not we are
absolutely live on the internet right
now so we see your comments darth mocha
and uh and and challenge you
that we are not in fact pre-recorded but
some of the trailers obviously are
handcrafted you know those they're not
being made up on the fly uh speaking of
game trailers our next game trailer is a
cyber noir point and click adventure
blending stunning retro design with
innovative mechanics i mean this sounds
great i'm already in choose your clients
travel around the world and solve
dangerous cases using real world
research
yep let's take a look at chinatown
detective agency
[Music]
i'm amira dharma from singapore
[Music]
hi
my name is leonie ko and i play amira in
chinatown detective agency
wow look at that a new fave
you here for the free wi-fi i'm looking
for a book
i'm looking for the histories by
herodotus from the get-go i thought she
was like femme fatale
hard-boiled
badass cool
what are you doing philip
i'm done i'm not going back
it'd be a waste of my time
but maybe not
the game art is
superb the aesthetics really let me know
what kind of character amiro was going
to be the vibe was like pulp fiction sin
city that was what i put into a mirror
i've never broken into the gardens at
midnight before
tiger lily is that a stage name or
something
i hope you guys really enjoy chinatown
detective agency badass female
singaporean private investigator i don't
think it's been done before i'm so hyped
[Music]
[Music]
yes i'm into it let's go
andrea you feeling that
yeah i love the mix of art styles i know
some people in the chat were like where
are their eyes but you can obviously get
a lot more detailed um character facing
um art in the text boxes so i like that
they're kind of mixing old and new there
i agree with you and to prove this live
not pre-recorded jpy3 said these
point-and-click games are really good if
you give them a chance i agree games
like this you got to just really sink
your teeth in i promise you'll like it
maybe the games you might like too
because our next guest is the creator
and director by the way of the upcoming
2d
and just hear me out roguelike meets
gothlike i'm not making it up that's an
actual thing okay the title is called
cursed to golf which is being published
by thunderful games so for those who are
wondering what that kind of mashup even
looks like well good news we have a
trailer it looks like this
product not yet rated
hi i'm liam edwards the director of
course to golf at chew high labs i'm the
only one that made curse to go
that's factually incorrect in cursed
golf you go
also you die also you die again
also you die over and over again golf
like
hit the green and take on 18 hellish
holes in golf purgatory in your attempt
to escape to the land of the living take
your time to line up the perfect shot or
go out in a blaze of glory just be
careful as with each new hole comes new
hazards new dangers and new friends
luckily you might have a few aces up
your sleeve these bizarre and world
bending cards add new dimensions and
make your journey that much more
rewarding it is up to you to take on
every hall fight each boss and find your
way out of this mysterious golf
purgatory once and for all it's a
golflike i'm liam edwards and this is
cursed golf
[Music]
curse the golf looks fantastic even
better looking right now is liam edwards
joining us right now welcome on to the
show at idx box how you doing
i'm good thank you i i who was that
annoying man i'm very sorry about that
you know what could be annoying is the
idea of a golf-like roguelike where they
say you spend your purgatory in golf
what is that what does that mean like
how do you
what is this
uh very hard to describe on the surface
level it's a game uh that kind of pokes
fun at the uh the jokey hellish nature
that some people maybe think about golf
combined with one of my sort of favorite
genres out there which is like
roguelites uh in this fun weird physics
based uh kind of
dungeon explorer uh we have 18 holes and
they're they're all laid out like
dungeons and they have fuller hazards
for you to overcome and you have to
basically golf your way around but on
top of that you have this uh card deck
of all these different power-ups called
ace cards and you're able to bend them
to your will to try and get through
every single hole if you survival 18 you
survive the game
now some cool things right now is that
people are saying things like love the
mashup concept and remnants saying after
golf story i love these blinds so i
gotta wonder
what inspiration did you have to make
this kind of game you said you you're in
golf you love these kind of hellish
style games was the particular moment
you were playing something you said you
know what this needs it's more challenge
uh
not it wasn't really started with golf
actually it was uh thinking about
roguelites uh as a game designer i think
about genres a lot of the time and that
mashup is exactly right which is uh how
could i match up some crazy weird things
and i thought about physics in a
roguelite and then that kind of
naturally just led to golf which is
something a game i played as a kid
actually and had quite a bit of
knowledge about it's not really
something i delve into now
but something i went through as a child
and had to suffer through so this is
kind of almost like therapy for me
really to be honest
it's a nice way to go back and say if i
have to suffer then guess what new
generation you've got to suffer too and
share it you got to suffer with me
yeah at this point though you are
actually dead so i don't know how much
suffering there is after death to be
honest uh i mean if you're playing golf
it can't be that dead right uh king
blade xx says now i like this question
right here does it have bosses
it does indeed actually you might have
sneaked a peek they're one of the bosses
uh they're not
bosses in the traditional sense uh
because they're actually kind of
supportive friends but they're
challenging you uh they want to make
sure that you you are the pro that you
say you are because before you died or
you know expired as we say uh you
actually were a pro golfer and uh the
start of the game is you're about to win
basically the largest golf tournament
that possibly could exist and you're
about to become the greatest golfer of
all time and asgrew swing that final
shot uh you're struck with lightning and
your uh travels through purgatory golf
purgatory uh is to basically prove that
you are the greatest golfer of all time
and make it through the toughest 18
holes you possibly can
so yes it is uh definitely definitely
about golf but kind of
i don't know a bit of a strange one
no i i like that it's it's like meet joe
black meets pga tour that's we're all
here for right now
it's a very good way to go about it
and for games like this that are so
tough one of the things i worry about
and wonder about and i personally love
is the challenge of the nature right and
the nature of the challenge so are you
someone who is so well versed in this
game i have to wonder what's the
challenge like what what makes it
hazardous along the way and what
benefits you
it's funny you say that because that's
something i ask myself every single day
as officially right now the world's best
player of course the golf um no what
we're aiming to do uh quite you know
roguelites is supposed to be challenging
and
in kirsten golf if you do fail a hole uh
you have five shots to finish a whole so
if you think of a traditional par five
but it's the inverse which is that's
kind of your health we have something
called the par count and if you run out
of shots on your par count you will
round over so it's up to you to try and
use these ace cards try and get good at
golf we have spin mechanics and
everything to add some nice little
platforming to it as well
but if you do fail then you return back
to whole one back to the beginning
there's going to be a lot of cards and a
lot of nice little boons and power-ups
for you to basically stall
that demise and try and ascend as best
as you can to the 18th hole
really quick question
are they randomly generated though
they are not randomly generated uh
unlike normal roguelites
golf didn't really suit the sort of you
know with golf shots you want to hit
like a variety and we thought like
random generation was not necessarily
the way to go to get the best out of the
courses so we do have over 80
hand-designed holes and then the way the
golf course actually works is it
randomizes
and kind of uses like a labyrinth system
to determine the difficulty of your run
so
even on your first run the first time
you jump into the whole one again might
not be the first hole again and you
might have an entirely different hole
and then it's up to you to try and put
everything together that you've learned
on previous runs and tie it nicely
together
well perfect we got the just up we got
some gameplay everything you possibly
want so where do we go to find out more
information how can we follow up on
updates on this
uh you can follow us on twitter at
youhai labs we also with our wonderful
publisher thunderful games they're
posting a lot as well so you can go to
their website thunderfulgames.com you
can also follow me on twitter at liam
bme because i tweet about this game all
the time uh like one of those terrible
people who talks nothing about their own
project
no that's that's the perfect kind of
narcissism thank you so much liam
edwards
thank you
that was fantastic it looks really good
we know less talk more games and
listening so we're going to do that for
you we're going to have another short
break and we come back more id xbox and
more games so
stay tuned
[Music]
hey you made it come on in are you sick
of hollow gestures and meaningless nods
of understanding thank you for your
services of civilians who think they
know what you've been through are you
tired of being repeatedly thanked and
told you're a hero
thank you for your service
crisis can happen unexpectedly to anyone
and though it may seem like a small
barrier a simple lock puts space between
the thought and the trigger learn how
securing your guns can help prevent
suicide
it's not twitch
without her
or her
or her or mind-blowing battles
press champion showdowns
extreme burden
the love love
[Music]
without you
[Music]
land is dying
but whatever comes
i will be ready
[Music]
your home
for romance
your home
for big savings
because when you bundle home and auto
with progressive your home is a savings
paradise
bundles progressive
your home for savings
[Music]
xfinity internet gives im brandon wifi
speed faster than a gig to game and
stream for his legion of fans and a
reliable connection for all his devices
so all he does is win
can your internet do that
phillips presents one blade trim
edge
shave for every style for your style
philips one blade your style made simple
together we make life better phillips
you're all in danger there are certain
rules to surviving killer's motive he's
always connected in the past
scream i'll be right back
he's dead
you can sell
a blank slate
a breath of fresh air
and a new purpose for very old things
squarespace is everything you need to
sell anything so far
everything is going really well the
games look fantastic a lot of people
have been saying i don't want just this
one game i want these one two or three
to add to my wish list and to prove that
we are not pre-recorded because that's
an ongoing tale in saga kyle c fritz who
spoke one minute ago said and i quote so
far the interviews have been really fun
and perfect amount of depth and detail
andrea that's us
that's so kind kyle thank you so much
for your lovely comment keep them coming
yeah shout outs to kyle good looking out
man
and speaking of keeping things coming
we've got more exciting new trailers for
you so let's take a look at what's
coming soon to xbox
uh
oh
[Applause]
here
[Music]
this is xenozoic a strange punk fantasy
world with even stranger inhabitants
in the chaotic society they live pseudo
a martial artist forsaken by his master
has chosen to live as a recluse
your adventure starts when he wakes up
and hears mysterious music which guides
him to the boy
an orphan creature whose incredible
powers have attracted the attention of
gemini the dying mistress of the
artifacts unable to leave the boy to
face his throat alone pseudo decides to
protect him unaware that much larger
forces are at play
chased by the servants and mercenaries
working for gemini you must use your
fist and your mastery of various martial
arts
which can be freely alternated between
based on the enemies you face and your
preferences
you learn new techniques and improve
your attacks as you progress and build
your own fighting style
one law reigns in zenozoic the ritual
if you wish you can challenge enemies to
this dice game before a fight begins to
determine the rules of combat
the winner applies the effect of an
artifact onto the opponent which can
include fighting in a cloud of fog or
having a chain limit their movements
far from determining the winner or loser
these rule changes present an
opportunity to be exploited if you win
the ritual or a challenge to be overcome
if you lose
outside of combat you'll wander this
intriguing world seeking out its past
secrets and shortcuts you'll meet
strange characters collect artifacts and
items that can be used to craft weird
objects that will aid your journey
and at night pseudostreams are so vivid
that they take on a life of their own
you wake up with a distorted visage in a
dream like xenozoic where new areas
become accessible and dark creatures
emerge
inspired by surrealism and punk fantasy
stories clash artifacts of chaos
promises to be an indie action adventure
like you have never seen or experienced
before
[Music]
i'm emperor t payne the devout holiest
of holies pope almighty
and i want to announce that i'm
officially
starting
my own religion
kaboom
you see it all began in the year 1066
when the pope wouldn't let me
excommunicate my wife
they said there wasn't enough evidence
of adultery but we all know the real
reason is because her brother was high
and mighty king of france mr gooded two
shoes catholic over here but then i
remember i'm a freaking paragon of
virtue
i look i don't know why nobody's thought
of this before
because it's freaking brilliant i'm a
medieval genius i got so much faith i
can just make my own religion where
divorce is legal kaboom problem solved
we'll call it check me
buddhism of course that's the loud
that's definitely allowed we should
encourage that
[Music]
it's gonna be a liberal and
forward-thinking religion uh uh a church
for the people that's gonna benefit
everybody as the leader of this religion
i will have the final say in who i can
divorce and or marry
ah
yeah see
probably should have seen that coming
good good for them
get it on xbox game pass coming march
29th
buddhism let's go
[Laughter]
he's making all the right moves making
his own religion allowing witchcraft
allowing adultery he just knows how to
play the game it looks like
i mean i i said on the break when we
were watching these trailers i was like
whatever they spent on deepain was worth
it because i'm loving these trailers and
i saw that in the chat um people are
demanding a stream from t-pain so maybe
we can get that once the game is finally
out
hey bryce 99210 says i'm a supporter of
buddhism you know what you me both you
me both but it wasn't just that there
were two other games right there too uh
andrew what do you think got a favorite
so i really love the art style of clash
artifacts of chaos it's got a very cell
shaded look and it's got a cute little
companion who doesn't like a good
companion npc
yeah i agree with 100 it looks really
nice and i like the first person mode
they show with the fisticuffs reminds me
of a game called breakdown on xbox looks
really good i'm pumped for that but
there's more games obviously and our
next game right here id at xbox showcase
is a perfect pick for anyone who loves i
don't know escape rooms which you know
probably haven't been a big thing the
past let's say two and a half years or
so you can't quite get off the couch
right but the team and i am eight bit
with shout outs to them
they were nice enough to send along a
full build okay of the game for us demo
live right here for the very first time
but
before we get locked into a room
together let's take a look at escape
academy
[Music]
what are you waiting for a room full of
memory gas is no place to relax
[Music]
impressive i knew i saw potential in you
ah there you are
welcome to the academy
[Music]
what's up
it's not the first time my arts conform
to
shreds honesty has no place at the
academy
hey there
enough water they're already hydrated
my star studios
[Music]
what the hell have we gotten ourselves
into
[Music]
all right are you ready to do this i
feel like the entire internet is going
to judge our
escape performance so hopefully we don't
disappoint
andrea we are two of the smart people
that i know so i have no fear whatsoever
ah thanks i appreciate the vote of
confidence and i also love how the
concept of this game is that it's
supposed to make you better at escape
rooms because it is in fact an academy
so maybe after this we uh we will be
escape room masters
yeah there was some context there too
but honestly i just want to get into the
game and i want to solve the puzzle
because i feel like we're being judged
and i will not be judged
so for everybody watching ocadrian is
controlling the game and i'm just here
to help him
solve the puzzles but there is a
multiplayer component but i'm gonna be
honest for anybody who watches my
streams over at what's good games you
guys know that i sometimes have trouble
multitasking and i get incredible gamer
face
and
because i wanted to focus on the puzzle
elements of this game i was like adrian
how about you just control the game and
i'll just watch
i promise to say things every now and
then just probably not most of the time
so i'm relying on you to carry us
through this conversation please
i am here for that and i also want to
give i am 8bit a shout out i saw you
guys in the chat
um thanks for hanging out with us on
stream today and we are you know already
got this underway so what have you found
so far in the world that you think might
help us should i get a pen and paper
going
maybe there's a bunch of sculptures that
have yellow markings on them some of
them have different things like that one
has a yellow dot right there this one
over here teases a maze and has a circle
in the outline down there there's a
plate splotch right there there's a door
that needs a key it looks like there's
some kind of thing for a nose and we
don't have it yet so
something's kind of a line somewhere
hmm okay so lots of yellow things
yes
something goes on this table it wants us
to use an item that we don't have yet
i think it's really interesting how this
game really kind of blends some of the
traditional puzzle elements you would
see in a point-and-click adventure game
but also
makes it
more
pressure-based because of the escape
room nature of it so i think people who
are good at you know old-school puzzle
games like you know my friends christine
steimer
will probably be really good at this
maybe i'll just have to
call her up and be like hey can you help
me
yeah if you're watching you know feel
free to like you know help us out and
say whatever needs to be
oh look at this
it's a painting but the painting is out
of order it has arrows on it so i'm
guessing it's up to us to put it in the
right order and figure out what
direction things go
all right this seems like it's pretty
easy
i believe in you you can do this
i believe in you
[Laughter]
i like that yeah go ahead adrian you
know good luck to you man it looks like
up
uh then right
uh then left
is that right
i see well i guess i don't know what
you're looking at
so right here on the screen the puzzle
has it's like someone took a painting
and just chopped it up and put it out of
order oh you're talking you're trying to
line up the arrows right
yeah i want the paint to line up so the
arrows go in order start from left to
right and i think the far most right
strip is the far left strip so the first
input would be up
oh
okay i see what you're saying so in
order to move the strips you have to
match the inputs
yeah
um
interesting
we'll come back to that
um wait what does that sign say how to
draw good but wait wait bananas
cheese wine wait this is my grocery list
we have bananas too we got one of those
so it's a oh look at that an arrow hmm i
wonder
this seems important
i feel like we need to prioritize
finding the cheese and wine because
those are always on my grocery list
caution wet invisible ink oh maybe we
need a uv light or something
oh look at this
it's a door that has uh colors which
means the colors have to go in a certain
order
interesting and that marked that yellow
mark was the mark that was on the ground
oh you know what i thought it was inside
this right here goes by colors right so
you can choose your color
this board right here has four items
banana cheese wine and well wait
i'm guessing banana is painted blue so
the first input is blue so we've gotta
find the cheese and wine to find the
other order
you know i
did not think that that's the direction
you were going with that and i'm not
sure that's correct but you know what
it's
i'm not sure that's correct but
[Laughter]
hey i wanted to call out i see a level
one gamer in chat is saying i've never
been around for one of these events does
this mean the announcements are over no
we have more announcements more
interviews more trailers coming we just
wanted to show you guys a little bit of
gameplay of escape academy from i am
8-bit and coin crew games which is
coming out later this year
this says because it's twitch we gotta
do some gameplay
we don't want to have a showcase and
have only trailers right
yeah absolutely
uh
wine
uh
banana
there was one more thing that goes here
according to the painting
the cheese gotta find the cheese
where do you find chicken
i feel like that's too easy oh look at
this arrow directions i bet that's the
puzzle
wouldn't surprise me the cheese was in
there we have to get through there to
find out or the cheese could be in the
garbage i don't see anything for no no
cheese and it's not in the trash
that's not where you put it
i mean it depends what kind of cheese it
is let's be real
that's 100 true that's facts
i gotta find cheese andrea
you think it's in that lock closet
or do you think it's something's in
there
um look back outside cause we haven't
been on here in a minute so
if i was cheese where would i be
beastly beno that is the question
okay
so we've got more
there is also a hint feature
if we you know
want to use the hint for the sake of
time
i don't know i feel like the internet
would never let us live it down
i mean i mean that's probably true but
all these things we don't have an
infinite amount of time to solve any of
this and let's we're probably not going
to solve it
we don't want to show you guys all the
puzzles right uh wait what'd you find i
like that
no the fact that you know we're not
going to solve this so
i'm just giving us an out adrian okay
i respect it
look
this arrow thing right here is bothering
me okay it's gotta be up
uh
i got it up
down
up down
right down
up down
right down
left
i'm wrong
i guess so
let's use the hand do you know how to
open your
inventory yeah right here uh
all the cheese already have it i already
had the cheese andrea
there it is
paint stained cheese creating arts no
picnic paint stained cheese
rather oh look at this it's a number
seriously oh
okay okay okay i see what's happening
here
one
three nine
we're missing the weight
one three nine
easy
i have to say i'm very impressed at the
speed at which you are solving this
i'm
flabbergasted there it is anti-missile
inc let's
[Music]
will adrian keep playing the game and
i'm gonna have to host the rest of the
showcase by myself who could say
many thanks so to the team over at i am
8bit for sending over the build for us
to check out and for you guys to take a
look at here on the stream today if you
guys want to get updates on escape
academy please follow at iamapet on
twitter and we look forward to solving
those puzzles later on this year
you did well adrian i'm very impressed
i didn't do well enough
it's okay you can feel sorry about it
later um but we do have a bit of good
news everybody tunic is now live on xbox
game pass and ash that high is playing
live on their channel and you can check
it out at twitch.tv
ash said hi
and you can find them in the control
plus app under participants or follow
them jump to their stream check it out
if you guys want to see some gameplay of
tunic and don't forget you can now
download it today
yeah that's the good stuff and if you
want to get an idea of what it's like to
play the game and to see a streamer's
reactions to it we're going to actually
take a peek in on asset high and the
good news is right now she can't hear us
she can't see us this is our own moment
to peek in
look at this moment
it's so concentration
it really is this is like we knew it was
gorgeous just right from watching all
the trailers and gameplay but there's no
way she's not any further than 5 10 15
minutes into the game this is the first
thing you see are you kidding me
i'm in i like it look at the
concentration on her face
that's like ash has the gamer face
[Laughter]
love it
if you guys want to check out more tunic
gameplay head on over to twitch.tv
ash set high hit that follow button and
check out their channel
i'm just
i'm still at a loss of words right now
because i i've only got one thing in my
mind and it's the fact that escape
academy has dropped me in my moral
victory but the good news is we're gonna
have a break right now and have a moment
to
decompress
and the good news is we'll have more
games right here idx box
so stay tuned
i'm gonna go play this right now
right now
[Music]
at steelseries we make the headsets mice
and keyboards that the world's best
gamers win the most
and we've been doing it since way back
[Music]
it's up to you how far you go
but whatever you do
go for glory
credit karma helps members get approved
for a credit card 66 more often with
karma confidence technology but if you
purchase art with wheelbarrow cash you
probably don't need a new card get the
money app that shows your chances at a
great credit card create your own karma
with credit karma
[Music]
baby i was born
[Music]
the stream has no idea how good it is
sometimes i need to give it a pep talk
stream you're not just any stream you're
the disney bundle you got disney pixar
marvel star wars and that geo on disney
plus you've got thousands of live
sporting events on the espn plus and
look at all your award-winning hula
originals you think every stream gets
those awards no way jose you're the best
stream
i'm the best streamer
real recognized real disney bundle
streaming at its best
so
[Music]
welcome back everyone to that id at xbox
showcase your boy occasion chillin right
here with andrea and we're bringing you
all the good indie games that you've
been looking forward to you for i don't
know forever
yeah
obviously forever it's been so long
but i digress are you ready to hit the
slopes for some snowboarding action i
know it wasn't the best transition stick
with me everybody shredders arrives
tomorrow on game pass an idea to xbox
showcase has the latest trailer but
first a quick message from the devs
behind shredders take a look
yo welcome to phone punch we're super
happy to launch the game this is the
almost the whole thing
so behind us is a bunch of boards so we
scan them in and that boot there our
photograph reboots and we're super
stoked that we can finally ride those
boards
in like away yeah let's do it thank you
for playing and have fun
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
doesn't it just make you want to catch
some fresh powder
it it does like i used to snowboard and
it means a lot to me because you never
forget your first concussion ironically
and i got micro snowboarding this brings
memories back it's just flooding in
so you're saying you've had multiple
concussions
well
if i did i don't remember them right i
do remember snowboarding is a blast
we've come a long way from the likes of
cool borders and 1080 snowboarding it
looks fantastic
absolutely i gotta take a look at this
back during the winter gathering and now
that we're almost into spring um you
know going up to the slopes is probably
not on my mind as much as going to the
beach but that's what's great about
video games is that you can transport
yourself to anywhere at any time and it
seems like the chat seems pretty hype
for this
oh yeah they've been waiting for this i
think in the top of the show people were
saying shredders shredders shredders and
shredders it's here and it looks really
good
absolutely but up next derrick bradley
the game director on fling talk is going
to be talking to ocadrian but before we
meet him let's take a look at the
trailer
[Music]
and breathe
the golden ground
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
in the faces
[Music]
we'll die by the light of the powders
blow
and laugh in the faces of the gods be
low
that what spent luck i'm okay dream i'm
joined by derek bradley the game
director of flintlock how you doing
homie welcome aboard
i'm good yeah thank you for having me
you know people in the chat are already
very smart about this i saw someone who
said hey you know what i loved ash and
that was their only comment which means
they know your history and they might
have expectations so in terms of how it
correlates to this game if you've played
ashton are you going to have a
familiarity with how this game is going
to play
[Music]
yeah you know um ashen was really
it was our first game at a4 so it's it's
a massive thing in the genetics of the
company
certainly all of that really
hard-hitting combat um all of that kind
of stuff but this one is very much um us
taking that expanding on it you can kind
of see the visual style um in in the
trailer itself and like how far we've
pushed that but that's expanded into
every other part of the game so um can't
wait to see what people think
i can't wait to see it either like the
thing is that intrigues me one of the
things that intrigues me the most the
fact that the game is called flintlock
you're you're holding a front lock but i
can't i feel like it can't be that on
the nose right like can you give us a
sneak peek or an idea of what that title
means if there's significance to the
flip flop
yeah absolutely you know um
it's actually quite an interesting thing
we took like a fantasy world which would
have had
dark magic and the undead and all of
those kinds of things and we took human
society to a tech level where flintlock
pistols and guns and all those kinds of
things had just been invented and so i i
suppose the whole proposition is like
how would this play out now how would
something like lord of the rings play
out if people had just invented
gunpowder and they were able to blow
things up and you could um you know
where a wizard would be all powerful
because they could throw a fireball at
you well now you could shoot a cannon
back you know
it's really interesting and like there's
a lot of really fun stuff we can do with
that um yeah in relation to those kind
of dark and terrible magics that also
exist within the world
you're bringing about all the dreams
people want you know i'm just picturing
moments of lord of the rings but he's
like i would cut off your head dwarf if
it said but and then flintlock and
that's the easy conversation to have
right there so you're putting everything
full front uh
one of the questions has been perusing
right now the chat one of the questions
i see is
i want to pet the dog can you pet the
dog pet dog bird yes no derek
you know this is
it's a deep question it is a really deep
question um and something that we we
don't really like to talk about you know
um i feel like
he's he's just got a lot of attitude you
know um and so uh i think so like
when it comes down to him he is kind of
the um
the epitome of all that all that dark
magic and all of that um
all that stuff that kind of the the
human technology opposes you know
just patting him might might be a bit
disrespectful to him i'm not too sure
you know we we're sort of still trying
to work it out with him um he's he's got
a bit of an ego you know but um we'll
see if we can convince him to let you
pet him i suppose
[Music]
you know derek i gotta say that was the
most political answer i have heard in my
entire life
and i love it so much
i think i think like petting the dogs is
so important you know it really is
we don't even know if that is a dog
because it has dog-like features is that
is that a constant companion does it
summon or is it just with us the entire
time
yeah so that little guy's with you um
the whole time uh he's essentially um
like your your companion um
he uh he you know where you bring all
that like flintlock weaponry you you
bring the the guns and the bombs and all
that kind of stuff that you could
possibly do um as a soldier uh
that little guy brings brings all the
dark magic so you'll sort of see right
at the start of the trailer he's got
his old bird claws and he's got monkey
paws actually on the front and he's sort
of covered in feathers um and he's got
horns as well but he's he's sort of like
a fox-like creature overall um and yeah
as you go through the game you kind of
figure out who he is and
and what his whole sort of story is
now i love the majesty of the setting i
i love the looks like a boss at the very
end that has the giant hole in his head
that kind of glimmers and glows the
entire time too so what kind of art
style are you looking to accomplish this
time around compared to ash
yeah because it's a big jump up for us
and as i say like i mean for every
single part of the the game from um art
style right through to character
progression all of that kind of stuff
it's a massive massive step up um for us
you know it's really just sympathetic to
the to the to the medium like what we're
trying to do at the moment and with us
kind of stepping into sort of this like
um
induct like pre-industrial napoleonic
type
tech level uh we wanted to really
portray that with a lot more of a
realistic style i suppose you could say
but also you know for our studio it's
just
invigorating to try new things to test
our limits and push as far as we can
and you've had success in the past
you've done some great stuff and the
funny thing about a trailer too is you
never know if the trailer is giving you
a glimpse of what is or wouldn't what is
not possible i know the other day when
we spoke in like rehearsal i was like
hey when i saw the ashen trailer and i
played the game it properly represented
right do you feel like this trailer
probably represents what this game is
going to end up like
yeah i think that's something that we
like sort of deeply believe in a4 uh
like all of the stuff that you see here
is captured in engine so we've
essentially just used the the spaces
that we have in the game we've used the
characters we have in the game and posed
them for the trailer um but it really is
just this is what it's going to look
like so uh yeah very very similar to
action in that regard
man you got to feel really good about
that too because people are they're
saying pot of things right now in the
chat they like the cinematics i think it
looks beautiful and of course they want
to find out if you can pet the fox dirt
bird doggo thing which we'll find out in
the future as you pointed out maybe sort
of kinda but if we want to follow
updates on whether or not that's
possible where can we get more
information
yeah absolutely like you can find our
website if you just search uh flintlock
or a4 games you'll be able to find us on
twitter you'll be able to find us on our
website you'll be able to find us pretty
much everywhere um google it and you'll
you'll see us wherever you want to find
us
that's my favorite answer is just just
google us you'll find us there so thank
you very much for that thank you for the
information and thank you for bringing
us this wonderful cinematic trailer
looks fantastic
i appreciate it
thank you derek
thank you hey that looked really good
right and
everyone i tried to get an answer but
that was some really really good
navigation by derek's the respect to him
up next andrea renee is going to talk to
two dabs from roblox uh looks like james
and madison and matthew huffton crave
director and technical director at
splittingpoint studios which is the
studio behind the viral hit wacky
wizards and high fidelity phenomenon
rolling thunder take away andrea
thanks adrian and welcome jansen and mad
welcome to the show guys how's it going
hello hey
yeah it's great we're real glad to be
here yeah we're excited
so splitting point studios has made
quite a name for itself within the
roblox community for making all kinds of
stuff but the latest thing that people
are talking about of course is rolling
thunder and this game you guys created
doesn't even look like it's inside
roblox it's just bonkers how long has it
been in development
yeah we've been working on it like for
like six months now
and um yeah it's just crazy like we
honestly haven't just started out as
like a hobby project and then we're just
like it's just gone so far and like the
graphics are crazy cool for like
streaming on demand and yeah it's real
fun
and you guys are no strangers to the
roblox community you've been
making content and doing content
creation for quite some time now um i
would say very well known within the
roblox community
how have you guys really seen the
journey not only of what you have been
doing as a studio but really where
the kind of ugc community has come i
mean it feels like roblox has just like
skyrocketed in the last couple of years
it has yeah it's gone insane i mean um
i've been on the platform for about 10
years um so that's like you know almost
my entire memorable life
since then and yeah it's gone from you
know basically being like a little
sandbox toolbox to um yeah what we have
today which is you know like so many
projects people are making the comments
on them
it doesn't look like roblox and um
it's gonna become a thing where you know
that that kind of thing where it's like
it does look like roblox now um just
because of so many tools they're adding
and you know um yeah you can see like
it's just every every day it's it's
getting
more and more
yeah
why don't i get it do you think that
this is going to be the wave of the next
generation of game developers i mean
obviously tools like unity and unreal
engine are always going to be important
but it feels like the kind of toolbox
that roblox is handing to young creators
feels
so approachable
yeah absolutely i mean like the
transition from like player to developer
like on roblox is so seamless and easy
like we hit this like literally like
every kid plays roblox right like as
they like grow older and they start
getting teenage years like it's
absolutely gonna happen like it's just
gonna be a natural thing like everyone
like you start going from playing roblox
to developing on roblox
so when was that period for you and do
you find yourself not wanting to go back
and play because you're doing just too
much work do you ever just go in and
like just mess around for funsies
[Music]
the seconds it takes to open a lock are
just a small barrier between the thought
and the trigger
[Music]
but it can change your life
learn how securing your guns can help
prevent suicide because crisis can
happen to anyone
in the coast guard your career is in
your hands
operate boats
pilot planes
learn to lead
in the coast guard you are a part of the
bigger picture
protect our ports
secure our waters
defend our home
don't limit yourself
expand your options in the coast guard
someone has to fight for what's right
like it or not
or walk in the same path
the only way out of here is together
[Music]
who missed me
[Music]
you in
let's go do something crazy
why don't you do coolest things
uh people need to read it i can't read
it
it's cause you're like four
it's not a half
switch to progressive and you can save
hundreds you know like the sign says
[Music]
i'm a millionaire
i'm not a millionaire
i'm a millionaire
i'm not a millionaire crypto is
complicated but as a tax expert with
crypto experience you can hand your
taxes off to me you do your thing we've
got your taxes into it turbo tax live
phillips presents one blade trim
edge
shave for every style for your style
philips oneblade your style made simple
together we make life better phillips
the secret's out now with xfinity get
gig internet and unlimited data with
xfinity mobile and you could save more
than 800 bucks gig speed internet and
wireless now that's a game changer join
the millions who save by getting xfinity
internet and mobile together switch
today
correct i put them on a clinic i like
that saying i do
see you in chat trying to defend your
performance in escape academy and don't
worry it's okay we all believe that you
would have solved the puzzle if you've
been given just two more minutes
i i kid you not i've been dwelling on
this for like 20 minutes like it has not
left my mind i've been sitting here
stewing in the background like but if i
had two more minutes and we're going
live are we because i want to play some
more so thank you for acknowledging that
see this is what happens when you let
him play a game in the middle of the
stream i told him that it was risky
but what's not risky is the chunk of new
trailers we've got for you guys let's
take a look at what's coming to xbox
soon
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello today we will show you a bit of
the new there is no light gameplay along
with a couple of unseen locations
hope you'll enjoy what we prepared for
you
[Music]
now we are located at frontier
pilgrims from all underworld gather
there to take their path to messiah
their savior
but solar corps kill any heretic they
can catch
[Music]
we took a secret path through caves to
reach the pilgrims camp
along the hero's way he will meet many
people and creatures who need his
support
help or not is your choice which will
affect the hero's karma
karma will be needed in future so be
mindful of your choices and decisions
first pilgrims camp
here you can gather some information
about messiah pilgrims and the
lighthouse of hope
some people can give you subquests with
great rewards so don't miss them
here they are
cannibals
they may look funny and stupid
but bloodlust made them very dangerous
and aggressive
[Music]
[Music]
here you can see karma door which can be
used as a shortcut
for using these doors the hero pays with
his karma
oh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
cannibals have strange architecture
they build their houses on top of each
other and that brings many conflicts
among them
[Music]
[Music]
a tough fight ahead
let's battle through it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
pilgrims believe that to clean your soul
you should look into holy water and
reject any evil within you
i think our hero has many secrets
because
his evil side is tough as hell
[Music]
uh
[Music]
there is no light is coming out this
year
man the twitch chat comments for there
is no light were hilarious
the cannibals living on top of each
other
i love it
i like that impression of it
i got pumped i got called out
they knew i would like void training and
i do like boy train it's it's trains
meets half-life if half-life was about
existential dread in the void it looks
great
i like that brennamania in chat said and
they thought it looked like a polar
express and snow piercer got into a
fight
yeah
that's about what it comes down to right
there
yeah uh battle of the trains
all of you
expressed some very intriguing sounds
during the whale fall trailer
you know i did because the fact that
whale falls started off with anime right
a very ninokuni style and i thought it
was going to transition into the
gameplay but there was this
juxtaposition right of the anime style
and then origami style artwork for the
game so that's why i kind of made the
ooh
oh like i was making that there is no
right sounds during the trailer
yeah it looks like the cut scenes and
some of the uh narrative dialogue
scenes in the gameplay are going to be
in that anime style and then it looks
like the gameplay itself you know is in
the um complimentary art style it's
interesting we don't see a lot of games
doing that
no but we do see a lot of games and
we're going to see even more including
this next game which i am extremely
biased towards right we're going to meet
the dabs and stars behind a little game
called oh wrestle quest
now wrestle quest is the only game that
allows you to power bomb suplex and
taunt your way through a massive rpg
world where wrestling action figures and
toys collide so before we you know meet
the team let's watch i've always wanted
to say this let's watch the
world premiere trailer of wrestle quest
and
now
introducing
the next great legend of wrestling from
humble beginnings to the electrifying
figure taking the world by storm
bravely embarking on an epic quest from
parts unknown the journeyman traveling
the world to take on the very best
he's here and ready to make his mark on
history
facing legendary challenges
the biggest name in town the man who
draws a crowd wherever he goes the
rising star that everyone wants to know
an unstoppable insurmountable
high-flying behemoth in the ring
[Applause]
[Music]
he's bringing out moves we've never seen
before
wow
can you believe it
one
two
three
oh yeah
grab your tights it's time for
wrestle class
[Music]
ah man this is my favorite time of the
day i've been waiting i'm gonna try to
do this as professionally as possible
welcome the founder of mega cat studios
james is with us we got the last outlaw
double j jeff jarrett is here and of
course a man mr five time himself booker
t thank you all for joining me for this
thanks adrian hype to be here thank you
what's up yeah
love to have you all here i heard the
adrian what's up in the background good
looking out of course first things first
big shout out to queen charmel well
deserved hall of fame yeah yeah you know
what it is
yes
mcqueen taking taking her rightful place
next to her king so yes beautiful beauty
routine
[Laughter]
yes sir uh happy to have you all here
today james want to start with you hey
you know what maybe you haven't held any
championships that i know of but with
this game right here i think you've got
a championship on the way tell me what
we're looking at right now what is this
you know i want to add that i'm
definitely starting out uh
wrestle requests here from a fan
perspective like this is a multi-year
three-year project where our team is
just so excited about
um although i've never never wrestled i
have powerbombed my children to sleep
and i often respect my team members at
the office so it's
we have insurance for it it's all good
and uh it's major creative inspiration
for us but you know so wrestle quest is
the world's first wrestling rpg
uh it's very much inspired
by nostalgia from the ground up it's
it's the art style it's the ip the
storytelling
if i describe wrestle quest really
broadly it's toy story with lord of the
rings storytelling
through the lens of a wrestling universe
so everything here is wrestling there's
no cave babe wrestling's always on and
wrestling is life
so it's very much packed in
every nook and cranny with just this
very very real love for wrestling that
we've transformed with uh just a number
of
amazing legends that we've had a chance
to work with like like jeff and booker
yeah we got some live gameplay right
here and book i'll start with you i
remember we spoke earlier you mentioned
that you were a gamer we were talking
about how in video games it's always the
pageantry in the entrance season getting
your brain busted off the top rope but
finally we have a game that talks about
the story element of wrestling you tell
me what that means to you
yeah that's the point of uh wrestling
that's near and dear to my heart i
always talk about the uh
shakespeare in the romeo and juliet the
phantom of the opera the encore the
bravo uh being able to go out and tell a
great story through professional
wrestling has always been the uh
the pinnacle of the professional
wrestler trying to get to that point to
a game like this the fans actually have
a chance to actually feel what it's like
to be inside of the game
that's big shout out to that and double
j of course you know all about wrestling
and storytelling and what it's like to
reinvent so can you talk to me about the
process that you were looking forward to
as well in this
game you know i'm coming from a ruffling
family i'm a third generation wrestling
promoter i've wrestled for over 35 years
and at the very core of it we're all
about an emotional connection through
storytelling and if you want to go back
to the you know the 80s with with much
old man or andre or or the 90s all all
through the generations it's all about a
connection connecting emotionally you
can have the greatest move set in the
world which is very very important but
at the end day you've gotta have the
characters you gotta have the persona
and you have to tell the story and and
and james and his team mega cat have
blown me away since day one day one
because that's what they've sort of
dialed into is the art of the
storytelling and russell quest is
certainly going to do that
i'm happy you brought that up too and
james to kick it off to you i want to
say first off thank you for including
one of my favorite storytellers my
favorite wrestlers of all time jake the
snake roberts i remember when i was a
kid his beep with macho man and the
whole earthquake sitting on damien's
story lines when i saw those as a kid i
legit thought they hated each other i
thought earthquake killed damien i
thought jake was blind in one eye for
wrestlemania 7. like i was involved in
all that so for you to include this kind
of stuff in the game that's big problems
yeah you know man it's uh it's been so
much fun to work on and uh the game very
much is just
layer after layer of
like our dreams of what we wanted to
bring to the games industry like most of
us were inspired by this era of gaming
by that era wrestling and uh you know
i'm in pittsburgh that's where our
office is we're a major sports town and
it could be blasphemous at times to say
that we care more about wrestling than
the steelers here but it's the truth at
the office
you know it's like
it's something we've we've just poured
our hearts into and i think i think you
can see it as you start to work through
the
storytelling in the game so it starts
off with a young randy santos who later
becomes muchacho man
you know his entire life is inspired by
80s wrestling so he's sitting in the
living room like many of us about three
to five feet away because it's an old
crd and he just glued in
and that eventually is what inspires him
to follow in the footsteps of these
heroes through indie promotions and
trying and pushing and all the character
development of you know getting found
putting your reps in um tapping into the
kind of tribalism and mentorship of
like senior wrestlers pulling under
their wing and working through the
character development through trials and
tribulations of
of making making a name in a world
that's that's full of other people
competing at the highest level
so it definitely has a lot of
playfulness on the aesthetics for
nostalgia but the storytelling we think
is just packed full with uh something
fairly representative of what we think
fantasy and the intersection of
autobiographical wrestling storytelling
is about
you'll look at that
and
sorry adrian i do want to add one more
thing so you can
tell that um muchacho man is is like
heavily inspired by macho man who's one
of one of the flagships
all-time yeah all-time greatest right so
he's um he's kind of front and center
into what inspires muchacho to follow in
these footsteps and throughout this
development you'll just see a number of
independent wrestlers and
legendary wrestlers that take part in
this universe as heroes that entire
cities are dedicated to so the way that
we're we're actually working with uh the
most legendary wrestlers is each one is
a statue of liberty style of monument um
where wrestling towns are founded upon
their legacy
same thing for booker and shermel you
know jeff of course has an amazing town
tells you all about the history of
guitars and wrestling and then third
generation promoter uh lifestyle yeah
it's very much like a um immersive
storytelling experience where when
you're working through these these
angles and i think this is really going
to be fun for wrestling fans
upon completing objectives and quests
dedicated to these critical paths in
these legendary cities
uh you have an opportunity to either
unlock them as managers unlock exclusive
story cinematics or unlock pieces of
gear and equipment that kind of inform
how your characters are built out and
how that progression takes place so i
just wanted to glue that that high-level
concept together because i think that's
usually the first question wrestling
fans ask when we have shown them the
game privately
no i respect that and that makes a lot
of sense and you mentioned to double j
so i'll go to you first do you have a
favorite wrestling town that you speak
to in this game or just in general
well you know what here's the thing that
i was just sitting here thinking i'm
watching the chat come in adrian this is
all kind of new to me this whole
it's
really cool
but
the the thing that that i that has
attracted me to the entire wrestle quest
no matter what town it may be is and
booker probably can relate to this
whether it's an action figure or video
game or whatever it may be through the
years authenticity is it for me it's at
the very very top of my list on on
getting engaged with it and that's what
wrestle quest is james just went over
point after point after point of just
how immersive the experience is and so
that is at the very top of the list for
me is no matter what town and look uh me
and
booker both have podcasts and you'll see
a little buzz in there of conrad tops
and my partner but
whether it's a podcast or in-ring
wrestling match you have to connect
emotionally and it has to be authentic
or it doesn't resonate and that's what
russell quest does it really resonates
with the audience
and book you know on that note it's got
to feel good too to know that
long after
everyone stops wrestling you know
there's always the legacy that carries
on in
this the ability to go back and recreate
moments to create your own storyline so
it's got to be impactful for you to see
that right
of course i mean uh
you guys i couldn't have um hit the nail
on the head i'm better
with someone like um savage you know um
savage um steamboat wrestlemania three
not just wrestlemania three in that
match but the leak the leading up to
that match you know when steamboat got
the larynx crush you know the people to
create your own stories i've been
reliving that story um i think for me
that's what i get out of this more than
anything is there again the storytelling
which i think is the the base of
professional wrestling
i 100 agree with that like i was saying
as a fan growing up and james i'm happy
you're taking the story element into a
game like this look i love i love
grappling i love creating my own
interests my own character but i fell in
love with everything i remember again
wrestlemania seven seeing macho man do
the elbow drop like five times warrior
gets up speaks to the heavens wins i'm
thinking oh my god my heart's broken and
then he reunites with sherry like to me
i saw people in the audience crying my
mom was crying i didn't understand look
at you man
i love wrestling man i didn't even
understand love and i was crying i'm
like i'm emotional i don't know why so
james how do you put that into a game
like this how do you capture all that
yeah
yeah
first i just want to jump in and say
that um thirty percent of our time
working
west is crying and the other thirty
percent is just marketing now because
it's like i can uh as i'm sitting on our
group introduction to wrestler class and
we're so excited to premiere it
getting excited whenever i hear booker
and jeff talking about the game we made
like it's just truly a dream come true
for the studio and it's it's just packed
full of every little piece of uh what we
love about wrestling
and the storytelling side can that's
really what it's all about with rpgs
it's gripping the characters there's
there's over 10 playable characters for
party building there's a number of
ancillary pickup characters that all
have their own unique hooks and
character agency that if you would want
to replay wrestle quest over and over
again you could still find unique ways
to
un
unwrap this this universe um
literally hundreds of quests and side
quests that helped demonstrate all these
different pieces that we've picked up
working with some of these legendary
folks the last three years
you know so i think ground up man it's
it's the podcasters it's the it's the
stories that they tell it's it's
reimagining them through this toy
nostalgic lens it's it's really just um
everything from the the items and
equipment and gear to the critical path
storytelling that just key to the main
gameplay
i do have some i'm bad news right now i
got the same name oh
i believe it i do and the problem is the
same man's sweeping right now i got the
oscar playing me off he's telling me
shut up wrap it up so
i want to say right now really quickly
each of you where can we find you and
find more information about you we'll
start with you booker then jeff and then
james
come and find me on twitter at uh booker
t 5 x that's on twitter and instagram
booker t
[Laughter]
twitter instagram and facebook twitter
instagram and facebook at real jeff
jarrett my world drops every tuesday at
6 00 a.m
nj you want yet if you want to get into
the ring and you want to get close with
wrestle quest it's at mega cat studios
and at skybound games
i appreciate it gentlemen this has been
a dream come true to me thank you james
for the wrestling experience booker t
thank you for everything that you do and
double j you can slam the acoustic
guitar on my head whenever you want to
bro so thank all for being here i got
one especially for you adrian i promise
thanks guys man thank you guys
this was an amazing experience everyone
as you can tell i'm geeked right now i
love professional wrestling but i've got
to shut up because this is not my show
and it's not all about wrestling it's
about id xbox showcase which is why
andrew renee is going to connect with
the lead game designer behind the
upcoming title floppy night so before
the devs join though we have a trailer
so let's take a look at that
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
what's good everybody and welcome to the
show christian it's so good to have you
from rose city games taking a look at
floppy nights how are you doing today
i'm doing well thanks for having me
so as the lead designer for this game it
feels like there's a lot of pressure on
you to get everything perfect are you
sweating right now are you feeling
confident about where you guys are at
oh yeah i'm sweating bullets uh but it's
good you know we've been we've been
working on this game for a pretty long
time we started development on it in
january of 2019. uh we working on it's
been a passion project ever since for us
so we're excited uh we're excited for
its upcoming release
well we were doing our rehearsals
yesterday i had mentioned that you know
you guys last showed this irl at pax
2020 which kind of feels like a lifetime
ago but with pax east looming it's kind
of exciting to think that you know indie
devs are going to once again get to
connect with people has the feedback on
your guys's previous games like you know
garden story and of course into the
world next door really impacted the way
that you guys have designed floppy
nights
uh so a lot of the way that we like to
design games is to make them a little
bit more accessible right we want this
to maybe be your first introduction to
these genres especially because we like
to match up genres a lot so flybase is a
mashup of like a tactics game and a deck
building game and you know a lot of
folks when they think about tactics
games there's a lot of math and a lot of
really crunchy rules and things like
that which i love but we want to make it
so that a lot of people can experience
this and a lot of people come into it
without being you know scared of how
complicated it's going to be so we try
to gear towards a little bit uh more
friendly more accessible we're able to
get into we definitely did that with the
world next door and we did that a little
bit with garden story as well
i love that you used the word crunchy
because it does feel like sometimes when
you get into the weeds with tactics
games it does feel a little bit
unapproachable and i think just the art
style alone kind of opens the door for
people to be like hey maybe this is
something that i can play do you guys
have a different like kind of difficulty
settings or is there a way for maybe a
noob like me to get in and not feel too
overwhelmed
no difficulty settings but uh i've hand
curated it so that a noob like you can
get right into it the game you know has
a lot of it has a lot of intricacies
because we're dealing with tactical
gameplay you want to plan ahead you want
to do the right stuff with a random hand
of cards so live it's going to be about
making sure that you always feel like
you can do something cool every turn and
we've spent hours and hours and hours
making sure that that's possible so i
promise you'll be able to you'll be able
to get into it just fine
oh looks like you've got a teammate in
the chat that says christian your
haircut looks great
thank you i got it just for this sure
[Laughter]
i i love it i love it so what
kind of inspired you guys to go in this
direction for this gameplay is it
because obviously rose city games kind
of has a really diverse set of games and
you guys portfolio was this something
that the team had just always wanted to
do
well the creative director marlo doby uh
she also worked on dicey dungeons was
pitching around with our studio founder
uh will lewis right and they were
talking to each other and they said what
if we did advanced wars with cards and
they passed that to me and i was like
what if you did advanced scores of cards
what does that even look like so we uh
we took that concept and i i buried
myself in a conference room and i wrote
on a whiteboard for a couple hours we
made a paper prototype which ended up
being this thing uh so it's a lot of you
know what if we took the games that we
grew up on she grew up on advanced wars
i grew up on final fantasy tactics and
made it you know just a little bit a
little bit different we've twisted it
with the new genre and we try to do that
a lot with our games right world next
story was you know match three and
puzzle solving was sort of a dating sim
thing uh so a lot of our games are what
if we took a cool thing that we used to
play as kids and made it even cooler
i think that's so awesome i love how
the flexibility of working in the indie
space really kind of gives you know the
smaller teams the ability to be nimble
and experiment and kind of you know see
what works did you guys find that when
you were you know doing the you know
pre-production of this game after you
did your you know your you papered it
that you found some things that you're
like hey you know in theory this feels
like it could work well but in
practicality it's kind of doodoo
yes oh that's just part of games right
so a lot of the stuff that i try to do
to the designer is make it so that games
do things only games can do right when
we started the game there's a lot of
like hard rules like only units can only
do this and get make cards out of this
and as we kept playing the game we're
doing more play tests folks were telling
us like hey this is this part's really
fun wouldn't it be cool if when you
played a card the card got better the
more times you played it and you know
going back to our rules like oh no no we
can't do that that's not in the that's
it in the design doc but
you know playing it over and over like
actually that's that's a really great
idea let's let's do that instead let's
do things you know let's make a game the
game does game stuff and we we take the
we take the good ideas we harvest them
all into finding the fun right which is
the really lame way of saying that
oh i don't think it's lame at all i
think that's why we all love video games
right it's all about um having a great
time and you know connecting with other
people about it um so for this game do
you would you say that it's a game that
people are going to have a kind of
crafted experience with or is there kind
of some
room to kind of have a little bit more
of a custom experience as a player
oh yeah there's going to be a lot of a
lot of room for flexibility so there's
multiple deck types right each of them
have their own personality we made it a
big deal so that you can mix all the
decks together no two decks look the
same especially on the dev side i like
to do something very specific my
my co-workers like to do things i
wouldn't even think of there's a lot of
ways to play this game in a lot of ways
to win every level right you just have
to use your mind and see what you like
to do with it
oh i love it i love to have a custom
experience that's awesome and hearing
people's different builds is always
really fascinating how people go in just
completely different directions
sometimes but it's what's so great about
um our gaming community everyone is a
unique flower um so for everybody
watching that is excited to check out uh
floppy nights where can they follow you
guys and learn more about the game
you can check out us at floppy nights on
twitter there's also at rose city games
you want to hear about the other games
our studio is making and we will be on
xbox game pass and q2 of this year so
check out that
awesome well christian thanks so much
for your time today and um good luck
with the rest of your development
thank you so much
all right everybody we are going to take
a quick break but don't go anywhere more
id at xbox showcase is coming up
including another game pass reveal
[Music]
we have one extremely difficult caring
let me speak to a manager
what seems to be the problem you're a
[ __ ] uploading should be accessible for
everyone we need to hold the greedy
powerful people accountable
you can listen in on any upload oh my
god look at her she's so beautiful
[Music]
taking the stage on karaoke night takes
confidence but it's hard to feel
confident when you apply for a credit
card with karma confidence technology
you can be more confident in your chance
of approval for a great credit card
before you even apply
create your own karma with credit karma
the land is dying
but whatever comes
i will be ready
[Music]
welcome to stockx the only live
marketplace for what's now and next the
latest sneakers apparel electronics
collectibles and more all 100 verified
authentic
with stockx you have the power to shop
millions of hard to find or sold out
products all at their true market value
because everyone deserves the
opportunity to get what they want stockx
access the now start shopping at
stockx.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
sally sold seashells by the seashore so
she set up a store on squarespace and
soon sold swanky seashell accessories
savory seaside snacks and even seashell
excursions of the seashore sally's
seashells were so successful she sailed
into the setting sun as a seashell
celebrity
xfinity internet gives i am brandon
wi-fi speed faster than a gig to game
and stream for his legion of fans and a
reliable connection for all his devices
so all he does is win
can your internet do that
[Music]
welcome back to the id xbox showcase i'm
half okay adrian half caffeine joined by
the goat andrea and our showcase is
almost over we've still got a few more
surprises left
oh yes get keep the caffeine going i
love the energy i love the segment you
did on russell quest that was super fun
we've had a wonderful show here today
but we still have a little bit more a
few more as ocadrian said and we are
excited to reveal this one here are a
few more games coming to xbox game pass
take a look
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
a first person murder mystery paradise
killer is now live on xbox game pass and
jermaine plays is playing live on their
channel so check it out on twitch.tv for
slash germain place that's
j-e-r-m-a-i-n-e-plays
you can find them in the control plus
app under participants and follow them
or jump to their stream like we're doing
right now andrea
i love it
i also love that in the chat uh jelly
dot said that paradise killer has a
crazy good original soundtrack which is
uh awesome because i love
music in games and i think that
sometimes soundtracks are
underappreciated in video games
yeah i 100 agree it's a it's a great way
to sell a vinyl by the way so have a
great soundtrack and give people
something to listen to but i agree a
good soundtrack sets to tone and gives
you a feeling of what it's like to play
the game we saw jermaine right there
cooking doing a dialogue sequence so i'm
already stoked to play it
you just want to watch people cook all
day
yeah i do cook all day hang out talk to
people solve murder mysteries preferably
in under like five minutes unlike some
people who couldn't do that earlier i
won't say any names but just a little
bitter
you know it's okay hopefully you'll be
able to get over it with
the fact that paradise killer is out now
live on xbox game pass so for everybody
who has been dropping all of the love
for paradise killer in chat you can now
play it on xbox game pass starting right
now it's there
what right now
yeah like right now
[Laughter]
yeah
like kind of like this last announcement
not last we still got more stuff you
guys the springs game spotlight is
currently happening which you may have
heard about that's five weeks of new
games and it's running from march 8th
through april 11th if you guys want to
learn more about the spring spotlight
you have to visit xbox.com
spring spotlight for all of the details
look at all these games right oh my god
they're going so fast i don't know which
ones are there that's a long time you're
gonna have to go to the website
i like that that's good i think i saw it
it'll be the show on there and i don't
know what else was on there i was kind
of looking away
it's a great time to kind of catch up on
games that maybe you didn't get a chance
to play which i know is a reason why a
lot of us love game pass is this really
convenient way to kind of check box some
of the stuff that's been in our pile of
shame which admittedly for me has been
growing into an embarrassing amount
and you know what you're not alone
people know this they recognize good
games as we can say right now as a not
pre-recorded message we're live a slice
of kiwi said game pass is the best
gaming deal in the industry and honestly
i'm hard pressed to disagree you know i
mean like it all looks very good so
it was a great show it was a great day
we had a ton of indies there was a ton
of stuff for you to look at too and of
course you missed anything you can
always go back and watch the vod as soon
as this ends you can have your own
little show or even watch it back with
your chat
so
thank you all for being here thank you
chat for you know conversing with us the
entire time thank you to the entire
production staff behind the scenes you
don't see the work that they do but it
looks fantastic andrea thank you for
being here with me you're the goat
oh it's my pleasure i love when i get to
work with you but i want to make sure
you tell people where they can follow
you and see what you've been up to
yeah sure my name is adrian you can find
me anywhere as occasionally i mean
anywhere twitter instagram ticktalk
twitch obviously i'm a 2021 twitch
ambassador i've been streaming for eight
years partner for seven and a half and
i'm playing everything right now
triangle strategy but that's going on
hold because tunic is gonna be in my
hands very soon so look for your boy
oh yeah i definitely have to download
that stat and i'm andrea renee you can
find me on twitter at andrea renee and
you can follow my show what's good games
at what's good underscore games or right
here on twitch at what's good games new
podcast every friday i want to give a
big thank you to all of the developers
and our guests who joined us on the show
today to share updates about their games
and talk to us about what they've been
making if you are making a game or you
have an idea for a game you want to
submit it to idea xbox you can get all
of the program details at xbox.com
backslash id for details maybe we'll be
featuring your game on the next id at
xbox showcase who could say but thank
you to everybody for joining us today
and to all of our partners at id at xbox
and we hope that you guys have fun
playing all these games
we'll see you soon thanks for tuning in
bye everybody
it was live
[Music]
team
you